the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi welcome once again to another lecture
on limits actually from a certain point
of view today's lecture will be the same
as the last lecture only from a
different viewpoint our lecture today is
called
limits a more rigorous approach and what
our objective for the day is aside from
helping you gain experience and facility
with using limit expressions and
absolute values and the like is to have
you see how we can use the power of
objective well-defined mathematical
definitions to find rather easy ways of
solving certain types of problems okay
now to this end let's very briefly
review our fundamental definition of
last time namely the limit of f of X as
X approaches a equals L means that for
each epsilon greater than 0 we can find
Delta greater than 0 such that whenever
the absolute value of x minus a is less
than Delta but greater than 0 then the
absolute value of f of X minus L will be
less than Epsilon to state that once
again but in more intuitive terms for
any tolerance limit epsilon at all we
can suitably
find another tolerance limit Delta such
that whenever we make X within Delta of
a f of X will automatically be within
epsilon of L and again the very very
important emphasis here we do not allow
X to equal a again in terms of a diagram
if this is the curve y equals f of X
this is x equals a this is L if we call
this L plus Epsilon if we call this L
minus epsilon in other words epsilon is
this width over here then the way we
find Delta is to reflect back to the
curve emphasizing again in a
neighborhood of the point a I can't
stress that
points strongly enough that if this
curve were not one-to-one there are
going to be other places where this line
meets the curve so if that happens you
must make sure that you pick the
neighborhood of a not some other point
over here we're interested in what
happens in your a but any rate again
notice that the fact that these two
intervals here were equal does not
guarantee that when you project down
here they will be equal in fact the only
time that these two wins would be equal
is if the curve happened to be a
straight line and what it means again is
that the Delta that we're talking about
for example is the minimum of these two
widths in other words as I've drawn this
diagram Delta would be the distance from
a to this endpoint and all we're saying
is that once X is in this open interval
but not including a itself f of X will
be in this open interval and again
notice as we're emphasizing last time
once this Delta happens to work
obviously or at least I should say
automatically any smaller Delta will
also work in other words if something is
true for everything in here it's
certainly true for everything in some
sub interval of this what you must be
careful about is not to reverse this
process don't get outside and pick
bigger deltas then you might very well
be in a little bit of trouble now at any
rate once we've reviewed what the basic
definition is it seems that about the
only way to show what mathematics is all
about is to actually do a few theorems
that is derive a few inescapable
consequences of the definition that show
how our theorems coincide with what we
believe to be intuitively true in the
first place and for obvious reasons we
should start with what hopefully would
be the simplest possible theorems and
then proceed to tougher ones as we go
along so as my first one I have chosen
the following the limit of C as X
approaches a is C where C is
a constant now again that may look a
little bit strange to you let's look at
it this way what I'm saying is let f of
X equal C where C is a constant then
what we're saying is for this choice of
f of X the limit of f of X as X
approaches a is C itself that's what
this thing says now how do we prove this
well you see we have a criteria given
namely what is our basic definition see
let's just Chuck's the position our
basic definition with this particular
result to prove that the limit here is C
notice that in this particular problem
if we compare this with our basic
definition if we come back and compare
this with our basic definition notice
that we have the same basic definition
as before only the role of f of X is
played by X is played by C and L is also
played by C in other words in this
particular problem f of X is C and L is
also C now what must we do we must show
that for each epsilon greater than 0 or
for an arbitrary epsilon greater than 0
now what does it mean to say an
arbitrary epsilon in a way think of it
as being a game a battle of wits between
you and your worst enemy and you're out
to win and your worst enemy is out to
beat you so to make this as difficult a
game as possible you allow your worst
enemy to choose the epsilon provide only
that's positive and no matter which one
he picks for whichever one he picks you
must be able to find the Delta that
matches that epsilon such that what
whenever X is within Delta of a but not
equal to a f of X will be with an
epsilon of L so let's write that down
over here let's write what that says
given epsilon greater than zero
we must find delta greater than 0 such
that what well by definition such that
when the absolute value of X minus a is
less than Delta but greater than 0 the
absolute value of f of X well that of
course as see in this case minus L which
is also see in this case the L stands
for the limit has to be less than
Epsilon
hello and behold we find that a this is
a rather simple procedure because what
is C minus C C minus C is 0
and automatically that will be smaller
than any positive Epsilon in other words
what this says is even your worst enemy
can't give you a tough time with this
problem namely no matter what epsilon he
prescribes no matter how sensitive you
say well for Delta I'll pick anything
and it works and why does that work well
here again we can emphasize the
geometric approach namely if we plot the
graph f of X equals C observe that that
plots as a straight line y equals C now
take x equals a over here what is f of a
F of a is C now pick an epsilon which is
this half with over here knock that off
on either side of C and all you're
saying in this particular case is no
matter how far away X is from a f of X
will be within these tolerance limits of
C and why is that because f is defined
in such a way that the output for any
element in its domain is C itself in
other words every element Maps up here
this is what you mean by saying if the
graph is the line the straight line y
equals C by the way another word of
caution we must always make sure this is
an aside but always make sure that your
diagram or that your solution does not
depend on the diagram
you see if a person were to look at this
diagram very quick
he would assume that si had to be a
positive constant here because you see
look at how I've drawn the line Y it
will see its above the x-axis
well secret just as easily be a negative
constant and if I drew the diagram that
way si would be below the x-axis the
important thing to check is this when
you draw a diagram you can't have a
certain number being positive and
negative at the same time so you choose
it one way or the other always make sure
when you do this that you formal proof
your analytic proof goes through
word-for-word
if you reverse the signature the sign of
the number that you're working with
though is make sure that your answer
does not depend on the G on the picture
that you've drawn make sure that your
answer follows inescapably from your
basic definition and notice that this is
what we did here we showed what that no
matter what epsilon we were given we
could find a delta in fact in this case
any delta such that when X was within
Delta of a as long as X wasn't equal to
a well in this case even if X equal a
there was no harm done but the point is
we want to keep away from a 0 over 0
form so we always impose this condition
but in this case once X was within Delta
of a f of X was automatically within
epsilon of C as long as epsilon was
positive because f of X was already
equal to C the difference was already 0
now again notice what happens here the
more pragmatic student will say why did
you use this long meth when it was
obvious from either the diagram or from
intuition that this is the correct
answer
and the reason is as we have already
seen and as we will see many many times
during our course the intuitive answer
and the correct answer will not
necessarily be the same the point is we
always want to make sure that when we
prove something the proof follows from
the assumed definitions in a logically
rigorous way now if it happens once
you've proved this that you can
intuitively recognize the same result
that's like a double reward because now
you won't have to memorize what the
result was you'll just use the thing
automatically but the beauty is that for
somebody who doesn't have the same
intuitive
that you have if he says it's not
self-evident to me explain to me what's
happening then you see once he's
accepted the basic definition and
assuming that he knows the rules of
mathematics he has to come up with the
same answer that you did and this is
what we mean by an objective criterion
for doing mathematics okay well this is
kind of an easy one let's do another
kind of easy one that's harder just make
some gradual transitions here but let's
pick another theorem here's another one
that sounds pretty self-evident the
limit of X as X approaches a is a fact
what that seems to say in a self-evident
way is that as X gets arbitrarily close
to a X gets arbitrarily close to equal
to a and if anything is a truism I guess
that's it so we certainly suspect that
this is a true statement and all I'm
trying to get you used to is not to make
a mountain out of a molehill not to have
you think that mathematics becomes a
severe thing where we try to find hard
ways of doing easy things but rather
that we can find an unambiguous
logically constructed language from
which all of our results can be proven
without recourse to intuition once our
basic definitions are chosen so let's
see how this would work let's again go
back to our basic definition you see
again what we're saying here is that
this is just the K this is just a
special case now where f of x equals x
you see the function is f of X in this
case it's X and this is a special case
where a is L now what are you saying
here you're saying given epsilon greater
than zero we must find the Delta greater
than 0 such that what such that whenever
X is within Delta of a but not equal to
a then X will be within epsilon of a you
know and now you just look at this thing
I hope and you say well you know there's
sort of a similarity over here how close
should X be chosen to a if you want X to
be within epsilon of a and the answer
quite obviously in this case without
cost to death again
is to simply say what in this case for
the given epsilon shoes for example
Delta to equal epsilon because certainly
if the absolute value of X minus a is
less than epsilon but greater than zero
then certainly the absolute value of X
minus a is less than Epsilon well see
don't be upset that the proof happened
to be fairly easy in this case more
importantly don't be upset that there
was a more intuitive way of doing it
remember what we want to do is to get
these rigorous ways down pat interpret
them in terms of what pictures wherever
the pictures are available and then when
we get to the case where pictures aren't
available to be able to extend the
analytic concepts again to see what
happened here pictorially notice that if
you start with the function f of x
equals x its graph is a straight line y
equals x and i'll risk some freehand
drawing here so in other words we
suspect that this is a it better be if
this says that all points on this line
have the property that the y coordinate
is equal to the x coordinate now what we
want to do we pick an epsilon and Mark
off a plus epsilon and a minus epsilon
and now what we want to find out is how
close much X be to a on the x axis in
order that f of X namely Y in this case
or X itself be within this proscribed
tolerance limits of a and you see what
happens here this is that one case where
it happens at what if you draw these
lines over and project down but by
proportional parts and this is crucial
here say even if this weren't the
45-degree line the fact that these two
pieces here equal would guarantee that
these two pieces here are equal despite
of how I've drawn this the fact that
this is the 45 degree line not only says
that these two pieces here are equal but
it says what that each of these pieces
is equal to each of these pieces in
other words again I wish I had Rama's
better for you but in fact the worse I
draw it the more
you have to rely on being able to
visualize abstractly what's happening
here what I'm saying is that this point
here would be labeled a plus Epsilon
this point here would be labeled a minus
epsilon and this is the pictorial
version of what it means to say you
could have chosen Delta to equal epsilon
in this particular case well that's
enough of the easier ones let's pick one
that gets slightly tougher and this one
gets tougher in one sense but
insidiously insidiously I say meaning
it's real sneaky simple in another sense
in other words it turns out that one can
reason falsely and get the right answer
just by a quick you see what I want to
prove next is a very important theorem
that says that the limit of a sum is
equal to the sum of the limits written
out more formally if I have two
functions f of X and G of X and form the
sum f of X plus G of X and I want to
take the limit of that sum as X
approaches a what this theorem says is
you can find the limit of each of the
functions separately first and then add
the two results now at first glance you
might be tempted to say well what else
would you expect to happen the answer is
I don't know again what else you would
expect to happen but this is a luxury
you see evidently what's happened here
is that we've reversed the order of
operation you see this says what first
add these two and then take the limit
what are we doing down here
first we're taking the limits and then
we're at it now is it self-evident that
just by changing the order of operations
you don't change anything we've seen
many examples already in the short time
that this course has been in existence
we're changing the order changing the
voice inflection what have you changes
the answer and in fact we want to see
more drastic examples later on I guess
this is one of the tragedies of a course
like this it's like I guess it's typical
of problems everyplace if the place that
the person is going to get into trouble
comes far beyond the time at which
you're lecturing to him it's kind of
empty to threaten him with the trouble
he's going to get into
so I'm not going to threaten you with
the trouble you're going to get into
until we get into it all I'm going to
say is that be careful when you say that
self-evident that we can first add and
then take the limit or whether we first
take the limits and then add in general
it does make a difference in which order
you perform operations well let's take
this just a little bit more formally to
see what this thing says truth of all
when we write something like this we
assume at the limit of f of X as X
approaches a exists otherwise we
wouldn't write this thing so let's call
that limit l1 in other words let the
limit of f of X as X approaches a equals
L one let the limit of G of X as X
approaches a equal L to now define a new
function H of X to be equal to f of X
plus G of X and by the way this is
something I didn't say strongly enough
in one of our earlier lectures and I
want to make sure that it's very clear
that this is understood and that is
notice that when you define H to be the
sum of F and G you had better make sure
that F and G have the same domain
because you see if some number X belongs
to the domain of F but it doesn't belong
to the domain of G then how can you form
f of X plus G of X G doesn't operate on
X by the way this is not quite as
serious a problem as it seems if you
understand the language of our new
mathematics and sets and the like namely
if the domain of F if the domain of F
happens to look like this and the domain
of G happens to look like this what we
do is is we restrict the sum to the
intersection of the two domains you see
in that way if we see in other words
referring back to our function H we
define the domain of H to be the
intersection of these two domains and
that way for any X which is in the
domain of H it automatically belongs to
both the domain of F and the domain of G
and so this becomes well-defined another
way of looking at this is what you're
really saying is that F and G must
include in their domain intervals
pounding x equals a and since you're
only interested in what's happening near
x equals a you don't really care whether
these have the same domains or not
provided they have what an intersection
that can serve as a common domain but
that I think is more clear from context
it's a fine a very very important fine
point it's a tragedy to try to add two
numbers one of which doesn't exist
one of us a tragedy is certainly futile
all right so at any rate though let's
see what this thing then says if we now
define H to be F plus G what we want to
prove is that the limit of H of X as X
approaches a equals L 1 plus L 2 now
here's the point again what does this
mean by definition it means that given
epsilon greater than zero we must be
able to find a delta such that when X is
within Delta of a but not equal to a H
of X is within epsilon of L 1 plus L 2
that's probably kind of hard to keep
track of so I've taken the liberty of
writing this down for you right over
here C given epsilon greater than zero
so that's given we have no control over
that what we must do is find Delta
greater than 0 such that zero less than
the absolute value of X minus a less
than Delta implies now what is H of X
its f of X plus G of X and our limit
that we're looking for in this case is
l1 plus l2 so mathematically see we
replace H of X by f of X plus G of X the
limit is l1 plus l2 so what must we show
that the absolute value of the quantity
f of X plus G of X minus the quantity L
1 plus L 2 is less than Epsilon and now
we start to play detective again this is
the expression that we want to make less
than Epsilon
so what we do is we look at this
particular expression and we try to see
what kind of cute things we can do with
it
now what do I mean by a cute thing well
you know we're assuming that the limit
of f of X as X approaches a equals L 1
among other things and let me write this
as an aside over here see among other
things what this tells us is that we
have a hold on expressions like this in
other words the fact that the limit of f
of X as X approaches a is equal to L one
tells us we can make this as small as we
want I'll use a subscript over here
epsilon 1 because doesn't have to be the
same epsilon that was given here for any
positive number say epsilon 1 the point
is I can make f of X within epsilon 1 of
L 1 just by choosing X sufficiently
close to a by definition of what limit
means so in other words I like
expressions of this form and similarly I
like expressions of this form and again
the reason is that since the limit of G
of X as X approaches a is L sub 2 it
gives me a hold on the difference
between G of X and L 2 so again using
the old adage that hindsight is better
than foresight by a darn sight knowing
exactly what it is that I have to do I
come back here and try to dock the
things up for myself the first thing I
observe is that this can be rewritten
see no calculus in this notice just
plain ordinary algebra arithmetic this
can be rewritten so that I can group the
F sub f of X and l1 together and G of X
and l2 of together in other words that
this is indeed nothing more than 1 the
absolute value of the quantity f of X
minus l1 plus the absolute value of the
quantity G of X minus l2 now the point
is since we already know that the
absolute value of the sum is less than
or equal to the sum of the absolute
values that tells me that what C
treating this is one number and this is
another number the absolute value of a
sum is less than or equal to the sum of
the absolute values what this now tells
me is is like an I can say that this is
I'm trying to get a hold on is less than
this but look at this expression this
expression is the absolute value of x f
of X minus l1 and this expression is the
absolute value of G of X minus l2 in
other words then since I can make f of X
as
but rarely nearly equal to l1 as I want
and G of X as close to L to as I want
just by choosing X sufficiently close to
a why don't I choose X close enough to a
so each of these will be less than
epsilon over two now again this calls
for a little aside when one talks about
epsilon that is a what shall we say a
generic name for any number which
exceeds zero or I could have written
that less mystically by just saying any
positive number
well if epsilon is positive what can you
say about half of Epsilon it's also
positive in other words if I had chosen
the different epsilon say epsilon sub
one equal to the original epsilon
divided by two you see then I'm
guaranteed what that I can get f of X
with an epsilon two of L 1 G of X with
an epsilon two of L 2 and now adding
these two together if this term is less
than epsilon over two and this term is
less than epsilon over two the whole sum
is less than Epsilon and it seems now
semi intuitively what I mean by semi
intuitively well this is far from an
intuitive job over here it's quite
mathematical it's rigorous in that sense
it's intuitive in the sense that I'm not
playing around with the deltas here all
I'm saying is look at I can make this as
small as I want I can make this as small
as I want therefore I can make the sum
as small as I want and the fancy way of
saying that is I can make it less than
any given epsilon and therefore it
appears that this will be the limit now
again using our old adage again of being
able knowing what we want to be able to
dock the things up rigorously once we've
gone through this it's now relatively
easy to clean up the details in other
words for those of us who are
mathematically oriented enough to say
the way you've proven this last result
is the same sloppiness that I was used
to seeing in certain types of
engineering proofs where people were
more interested in the result than with
the answer I still don't see how you've
used the epsilon and the deltas here let
me show you what a simple step it is to
now go from the semi rigorous approach
to the completely rigorous approach all
we do is
we would what was done before in fact
you know this is true in most
mathematics you take a geometry book and
as a theorem it says something like if
ABC and D are true then e is true and
you learn this proof quite mechanically
you sort of memorize it we know the man
who proved that theorem didn't in
general start out saying I wonder what
happens if ABC and D are true in general
what he tries to do is to prove that
some result like a is true and as he's
proving it
he hits pitfalls he says you know if I
could only be sure a was true I could
get over this first pitfall and if I
could be sure B was true I get over the
second pitfall etc and when he makes
enough assumptions to get over all the
pitfalls and he has his answer he then
writes down the answer in the reverse
order from which he invented it namely
he says what suppose ABC and D are true
let's prove that E is true and the
student is then robbed of any attempt to
see intuitively how this whole thing
came about as a case in point let me
show you what I'm driving at here my
first exposure to formal limit proofs
was something like this when somebody
said prove the limit of a sum equals the
sum of the limits something like this
would happen
the first statement in the book would
say given epsilon greater than zero let
epsilon one equal epsilon over two now I
respected my teacher I respected the
author of the book if he says let
epsilon one equal epsilon over two
alright fine we can do that and more to
the point it turned out that the problem
worked if you did that but the pact that
bothered me is why did he say epsilon
over two why not two epsilon over three
our epsilon over five our epsilon over
6872
why epsilon over two and the point was
that he had ceded he had already done
the problem the way we had over here and
knowing what he needed then came back
here and said let epsilon one equal
epsilon over two and notice how this is
going to mimic everything we said before
for this choice of epsilon one we can
find a delta one greater than 0 such
that if the absolute value of x minus a
is less than Delta 1 but greater than
zero
then the absolute value of f of X minus
l1 is less than epsilon 1 why do we know
that that's the definition of what it
means to say that the limit of f of X as
X approaches a equals l1 in a similar
way he says we can find Delta 2 greater
than zero such that whenever the
absolute value of X minus a is greater
than zero but less than Delta over two
we can make the absolute value of G of X
minus L sub two and be less than epsilon
1 and now comes the beautiful step he
says now that these Delta 1 and Delta 2
exist separately pick Delta to be the
minimum of these two in other words if I
let Delta equal the minimum of these two
what does that guarantee me if Delta is
the minimum of these two it guarantees
me that both of these conditions are met
at the same time see what does that tell
me it tells me that as soon as the
absolute value of X minus a is less than
Delta but greater than zero
automatically these two conditions hold
and that in turn tells me what that the
absolute value of f of X minus L 1 is
less than epsilon 1 and the absolute
value of G of X minus L 2 is less than
epsilon 1 and now by adding unequals 2
equals that tells me what that this Plus
this is less than 2 epsilon 1 but see
using my hindsight I picked epsilon 1 to
be what epsilon over 2 so 2 epsilon 1 is
just another way of saying Epsilon in
other words what this now implies is
that the absolute value of f of X minus
L 1 plus the absolute value of G of X
minus L 2 is less than 2 epsilon 1 which
equals Epsilon
but you see this in turn this in turn is
what this is greater than the absolute
value of f of X minus L 1 plus G of X
minus L 2
and so this was the thing we wanted to
make smaller than Epsilon since this is
smaller than this and this is already
smaller than Epsilon then this must be
smaller than epsilon to again notice
this is rigorous but if you understand
what's happening here piece by piece you
never really have to memorize a thing
see let's just take a look back here to
reinforce what I'm saying here notice
what we did we started with the answer
that we wanted to show worked around to
get a hold of things that we wanted we
were lucky enough and this is true in
any game for example one can plot
masterful strategy and still lose
there's no guarantee we're going to win
without masterful strategy but we
usually do in this course usually what
we do is we masterfully come back to
this see what has to be done knowing
what the right answer is got to be we
come back here and then formalize it
essentially what we do is reverse the
steps here I guess there is one thing
that bothers many people that I should
make an aside about why do you need a
different Delta 1 and Delta 2 for the
same epsilon 1 see if you're memorizing
there's again a danger that you won't
realize this and why this happens let me
show you in terms of a picture what this
means see let this for the sake of
argument be the curve y equals f of X
and let this be the curve y equals G of
X okay all we're saying is this that
when you prescribe an epsilon the same
epsilon that surrounds l2 if you have
that surrounds l1 because the curves may
have different slopes that what happens
over here even as badly as I've drawn
this notice that an epsilon neighborhood
of l2 projects down into this size
neighborhood around a on the other hand
an epsilon neighborhood of l1 you get
what you pay for I guess look at anyway
an epsilon neighborhood of l1 projects
into a much smaller region and by the
way that's exactly what we meant this is
a Delta one for example
this is Delta 2 and when we said pick
Delta to be the minimum of Delta 1 and
Delta 2 all we were saying was listen if
we guarantee that X stays in here then
certainly both of these two things will
be true at the same time well again we
have many exercises and reading material
to reinforce these points all I want to
do with the lecture is to give you an
overview as to what's happening so she
see these things and I'm afraid I might
kill you with details if I just keep
hammering home these rigorous little
points I as I say I hope you get the
main idea from what we're doing
let me just for the sake of argument try
to work with just one more idea and
we'll see how this works out also let's
for example try to play around with the
idea a corollary to the limit another
corollary a companion to the limit of a
sum equals a sum of the limits would be
what the limit of a product equals the
product of the limits in other words
again as before if the limit of f of X
as X approaches a is l1 and a limit of G
of X as X approaches a is l2 let's form
a new function which we could call K of
X which is equal to the product of F and
G again noticing that the product that F
and G have to have a common domain here
that you want to show that the limit of
f of X times G of X is l1 times l2 ok
now what happens is and this is the hot
part of the course this is the pilot of
course that I don't think anybody in the
world can really teach all one can do is
try to expose the student to ideas and
hope that the student has the knack of
putting these things together to form
his own repertoire the idea is something
like this I'll show you alternative
methods and the like
one way is we want to get a hold of f of
X times G of X now what do we have a
hold on it's a very clever what we do
here we have a hold of f of X minus l1
and we have a hold of G of X minus l2 so
as we so often do in mathematics we
simply add and subtract the same thing
you know if we frequently add on 0 just
in this cute way
we add and subtract the same thing
notice what we did over here we wrote f
of X as L 1 plus f of X minus L 1 again
why did we do that because from our
definition of the limit of f of X as X
approaches a equals L 1 we know that we
can control this size and the same thing
is true over here the fact that the
limit of G of X as X approaches a equals
L 2 means we have some control over this
now let's just multiply everything out
see this is what f of X times G of X but
we just saved myself some space and keep
the board somewhat symmetric when I
multiply these terms out I'm going to
get what an l1 times l2 term over here
as one of my four terms let me already
transpose that one so I killed two birds
with one stone
one is I keep a little bit of symmetry
and what I'm going to write and secondly
notice that later on this is what I want
to get a hold on in other words notice
that the prove at the limit of f of X
times G of X as X approaches a is l1
times l2 this is precisely the
expression that I must make small our
show can be made as small as I wish just
by picking X sufficiently close to a and
again I will not go through all the
details here I will simply outline what
we do here namely let's multiply out the
rest of this thing we have what here
this times this which is what l1 times G
of X minus l2 then we have this times
this which is l2 times f of X minus l1
C and now we have what this times this
that's f of X minus l1 times G of X
minus l2 now the point is this is the
thing that we'd like to make very small
in absolute value well again the
absolute value of this is equal to the
absolute value of this which is less
than or equal to and I'm going to go
through these details rather rapidly and
allow you to fill these in for yourself
all I'm using is what that the absolute
value of a sum is less than or equal to
the sum of the absolute values the
absolute value of a product is
equal to the product of the absolute
values so this is going to be less than
or equal to just break these things up
and now you see what the key idea is l1
and l2 are certain fixed numbers fixed
numbers notice that because G of X can
be made as close to l2 as I want and f
of X can be made as close to l1 as I
want notice that no matter what epsilon
I'm given I can certainly make this as
small as I wish just by picking X close
enough to a for example for a given
epsilon how many terms do I have here 1
2 3 well you know to make this whole sum
less than epsilon it's sufficient to
make each of these three factors less
than epsilon over 3 well I can make
these 2 less than epsilon over 3 pretty
easy how do I make this less than
epsilon over 3 and the answer is if you
want this times this to be less than
epsilon over 3 where these are positive
numbers make each of these less than the
square root of epsilon over 3 then when
you multiply these two together this
times if this is less than this and this
is less than this this times this will
be less than epsilon over 3 and now what
you see what we do is very simple to
finish this proof off all we do now is
say let epsilon greater than 0 be given
choose epsilon 1 to equal epsilon over 3
choose epsilon 2 to equal epsilon over 3
choose epsilon over 3 at epsilon sub 3
and epsilon sub 4 to each be the square
root of epsilon over 3 then we can find
Delta 1 Delta 2 Delta 3 Delta 4 etc
clean up all of these you see and Delta
to be the minimum of the 4 Delta's
involved again this is done much more
explicitly both in the text and in the
exercises I just want you to get an
overview here and by the way while we're
speaking of this there's always the
danger that some of you may respect the
professor too much so that danger is one
I don't mind living with
the problem is this you may get the idea
out of respect for me that I have
invented a unique proof here let me tell
you this one I did not invent this proof
- it is not unique there are many
different ways of proving the same
result for example a person being told
to work on this and I'm not going to
carry the details out here but a person
being told to work on something like
this might have decided that instead of
doing the clever thing that we did
before he was going to do the clever
thing of adding and subtracting l1 times
G of X because you see if he did that
what would happen he could now factor
out the G of X from here and rewrite
this as G of x times f of X minus l1 C
and then these two terms could be
combined together where you factor out
an l1 times what G of X minus l2 and
even though the details would have been
considerably different the intuitive
approach would have been well look at
this is pretty close to l2 when X is
small our next is near a this I can make
as small as I want similarly I can do
the same things over here and pretty
soon you've got the idea that you can
make this sum as small as you want just
by choosing these sufficiently small and
there's no unique way of doing this
now his the main point are a main point
once all this work has been done for a
wide variety of problems we never again
have to use an epsilon or a delta let me
illustrate with one problem let's
suppose we were given the problem limit
of x squared + 7 X as X approaches 3 and
we want to find that limit our intuitive
thing would be to do what let X equal 3
in which case we get 9 plus 21 is 30 but
we know by now that this instruction
says that X can't equal 3 this is the
problem we got what appears to be a nice
answer that we believe in but by an
illegal method can we use our legal
methods to gain the same result and the
answer is yes because you see what is X
at +7 x it's the sum of two functions
and we've just proven that the limit of
a sum is the sum of the limits see for
example what I can say is this I don't
know if this is true what I do know is
true is that the limit of x squared as X
approaches 3 the limit of x squared plus
seven X as X approaches three is the
limit of x squared as X approaches three
plus the limit of seven X as X
approaches three how do I know that I've
proven that the limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits now what is this this
is really a product this is really the
limit of x times X but we already know
that the limit of a product is the
product of the limits see we prove that
theorem oh we almost proved it certainly
close enough so I think that we can say
that we did and this is a product also
so you see we can get from here to here
to here just by our theorems now didn't
we also prove as one of our theorems
earlier that the limit of X as X
approaches a is a itself sure we did in
particular then the limit of X as X
approaches three has already been proven
to be 3 so this is 3 this is 3 what is
the limit of 7 as X approaches 3 well 7
is a constant we already proved that the
limit of a constant as X approaches a is
that same constant so what is the
constant here it's 7 and what's the
limit of X as X approaches 3 that's 3 so
by using our theorems we get from what
from here to here to here to here and
now hopefully from a therm that comes
from someplace around the 3rd grade 3
times 3 is 9 7 times 3 is 21 but some is
30 and now you see this is no longer a
conjecture this follows inescapably from
the rules of our game from the rules and
our basic definition by the way you may
have a tendency to feel when you see
something like this that uh why did we
need the Epsilon's and Delta's in the
first place wasn't it a terrible waste
well two things first
we couldn't prove our theorems without
the Epsilon's and deltas and secondly
and don't lose sight of this in many
real-life situations
you may very well be faced with the type
of a problem that doesn't ask you to
prove that the limit of x squared plus
7x is 30 as X approaches 3 but rather
might say how close must X be chosen to
3 if we want x squared plus 7x to be
less than 30 point O to 3 and then you
see if that's the kind of a problem you
have these new theorems will not solve
that problem for you so we're not making
a choice here all we're saying is that
the Epsilon's and deltas are the
backbone of limits but that fortunately
through mathematical theorems we can get
simpler ways of getting important
results and that was our main purpose of
today's lecture these two things that
completes our lecture for today and so
until next time goodbye funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate